[Music]
foreign
hello
we have a little bit of a situation we
wanted to run by you Mobius wow great to
see you again
that that's what's been happening wow
time slipping were you times you know
that yeah you've seen that yeah can you
fix that no
it's impossible to time slip in the TVA
I know but we just saw it happen
[Music]
I've been pulled through time
between the past and the present hello
if what I saw is true
[Applause]
[Music]
this world and other destruction only
one way to find out
a good old-fashioned legwork
listen we have different styles you're a
man of action which is fine
I take a more slow deliberate cerebral
approach
it's really good buy
[Music]
it's up to us
to save this place is this cracked okay
whatever we do
we're playing God
we are gods
but how do you how do you choose
who lives
and who dies
make the hard choice
[Music]
always happen
always will be
all over the top don't you think
I thought it was spot on
thank you